[Musica]
Bari anno 1995
voi non sapete quanto siete fortunati ad
essere qui e non la
immaginatevi una piccola bambina che
cresce in questo posto con un solo sogno
nella testa
diventare Sailor Moon
Sì avete sentito bene Sailor Moon
l'eroina dei miei sogni
da bambina Quando giocavo con le mie
amiche volevo essere io Sailor Moon ero
Troppo timida per esprimere i miei
desideri ad alta voce non usavo Mai dire
che volevo essere lei Infatti Sailor
Moon interpretava sempre una bambina con
i capelli biondi lunghi e bellissimi era
perfetta per il ruolo troppo perfetta e
così nel nostro gruppetto lei divenne
Sailor Moon
volete sapere che ero io
No non Sailor Mars quella rossa col
personaggio dal ruolo forte e saggio
nemmeno Sailor Jupiter La sportiva del
gruppo del resto ho sempre odiato lo
sport Beh però almeno avevamo lo stesso
colore di capelli Peccato che le
somiglianze finissero lì
No nemmeno l'una La gatta di Bunny ma
Sailor Venus
somiglianze nessuna Ma allora bionda per
bionda Almeno per una volta Fatemi
essere Sailor Moon
ciò che trovo affascinante di lei era
come una bambina normale che viveva
sulla terra
potesse diventare un eroina che
proteggeva e salvava l'umanità e la
verità era che io non mi sentivo affatto
rappresentata la Sailor Venus
vedete Questo è un esempio di come i
personaggi dei media possono influenzare
le nostre vite e le percezioni di noi
stessi
Se non riesci a trovare un personaggio
in cui rappresentarti la cosa migliore
che possa accadere che tu ti senta
invisibile la cosa peggiore è ricorrere
a un'immagine stereotipata e realistica
i media hanno il potere di farci sentire
rappresentati di farci sentire eroine ed
eroi oppure di non farci sentire
rappresentati di conseguenza diventare
invisibili
da queste riflessioni è nato il progetto
vera
lei è vera
Ok non è vera o meglio sì lei è vera Nel
senso che il suo nome si chiama proprio
vera il suo nome vera wise
vera È un'umana digitale un personaggio
inventato in cui mi piacerebbe che
alcune donne si rispecchiassero
per costruire il suo personaggio ho
fatto alcune scelte
assegnandole delle caratteristiche che
potessero rappresentare le minoranze
ha un corpo curvy Mediterraneo ha una
preferenza sessuale A lei piacciono le
donne ha delle passioni la fotografia la
moda la musica e videogiochi E ha a
cuore la sostenibilità ambientale e
l'inclusività
Vera ha una vita di ricordi come la
nostra a differenza che i suoi sono
stati creati con intelligenza
artificiale
cosa potrei raccontarvi al suo passato
Ha trascorso la sua infanzia in
Inghilterra
amava correre tra le lande inglesi e le
piaceva sentire
l'erba sotto i piedi nudi
anche lei ha vissuto un trauma come
molti di noi da bambina si trovava al
circo E venne fotografata accanto a un
Clown che aveva sulle spalle un
pappagallo con le ali tagliate
da allora ha il terrore per i clown
Infatti non è mai più entrate in un
circo
Come darle torto
ha una vita digitale come un normale
essere umano
ha dei profili Social e condivide la sua
vita privata su internet attraverso post
e storia
Pubblica foto perché vuole immortalare
il momento perché magari la luce È
perfetta E magari perché in vacanza e
poi capita di pubblicare quella foto in
costume da bagno Sì proprio quella e qui
c'è il bello cari miei perché ogni volta
che una donna Pubblica una foto in
costume da bagno c'è sempre qualcuno
pronto a lasciare un commento carino
ed è matematico esattamente come la
telefonata Dopo aver visto il video di
sadako di The Ring ve la ricordate 7
giorni
e non c'è niente da fare anche una donna
virtuale come vera non può evitare
questi commenti fastidiosi
Internet è davvero un'invenzione
straordinaria si possono fare tante cose
su internet alzi la mano chi Almeno per
una volta ha giocato a scacchi online
Chi ha mai fatto una esperienza in
realtà virtuale
Chi ha mai chattato online
qui siamo un po' di più
chi si è innamorato online
Che teneri che siamo
[Risate]
ma non sottovalutate il potere di questa
esperienza virtuali
alcuni persone potrebbero ritenere che
ciò che accade in questo mondo abbia
meno valore di quello che accade nella
vita reale perché non si tratta di
esperienze fisiche e concrete
le esperienze virtuali hanno un impatto
reale sulla nostra vita di tutti i
giorni
quando ci immergiamo nel mondo virtuale
entriamo in contatto con emozioni
sensazioni e persone reali
le relazioni che creiamo online sono
vere almeno per quanto riguarda le
emozioni che proviamo Inoltre questa
esperienza possono avere effetti
positivi sulla nostra vita quotidiana
perché possono aiutarci a superare le
paure a sviluppare la nostra creatività
e imparare cose nuove
d'altro canto le esperienze negative in
questo mondo possono influenzarci
negativamente
i commenti di odio Che riceviamo online
ci fanno male anche nella vita reale
per questo motivo è importante ricordare
che
ci sono sempre delle persone come noi
che leggono i commenti che provano
emozioni che possono avere degli effetti
significativi sulla propria vita
aver creato il personaggio di vera per
me È un'opportunità per parlare di
umanità
Per sensibilizzare le persone a
comportarsi in maniera etica e
rispettosa dei diritti umani nella
nostra vita online
ricorderete la terribile storia di
Daniele 24 anni della provincia di Forlì
che dopo un anno di
relazione virtuale con la sua fidanzata
scopre che in realtà non esisteva e si
toglie la vita
si trattava infatti di un uomo di 64
anni nel suo stesso paese
il fenomeno è chiamato Catfish quando
una persona si spaccia online per
un'altra ma tragedia nella tragedia
anche l'uomo si toglierà la vita dopo
che sarà sottoposto alla Gogna pubblica
grazie Un noto programma televisivo
Questo è un esempio perfetto
dell'impatto che la vita online ha sulla
vita reale
comportandosi in maniera scorretta
online possono avvenire drammatiche
conseguenze
ma il digitale può avere anche
conseguenze positive
se vi dicessi che grazie a internet
ai videogiochi si può prevenire il
suicidio o la depressione
uno studio clinico pubblicato su
frontiers nel 2021 ha esaminato un
videogioco commerciale in cui i
giocatori viaggiano attraverso il
deserto
nelle aree sotterranee fin sulla cima di
una montagna innevata
i giocatori comunicano con un singolo
tono
e possono volare se energizzati da altri
giocatori i personaggi non hanno le
braccia non c'è conflitto è l'unico modo
per andare avanti nel gioco è la
collaborazione tra i giocatori più sono
vicini più Sono potenti
nel videogioco avvengono due cose il
confronto ripetuto col potenziamento il
rifiuto ambiguo al momento della
disconnessione del compagno di gioco
questo meccanismo consente ai giocatori
di reinterpretare l'esperienza della
perdita come meno catastrofica o
personale
durante l'intero studio i partecipanti
hanno diminuito i sintomi depressivi
sono diventati meno sensibili al rifiuto
e hanno sperimentato più speranza e
ottimismo hanno esercitato delle abilità
emotive che sono
Vitali per la salute mentale
Ma perché ho scelto un numero digitale
semplice perché gli umani digitali sono
una via per raggiungere un pubblico più
vasto e diversificato per farlo Utilizzo
dei vicoli alternativi come i social
media le illustrazioni videogames per
raggiungere appunto persone che
altrimenti sarebbe difficile da
coinvolgere
attraverso vera avviene un corto
circuito
una persona virtuale parla di umanità Ed
è proprio questo che la rende
interessante
Ma perché interagiamo con gli umani
digitali cosa ci spinge a comunicare a
creare relazioni con qualcuno che non
incontreremo mai nella nostra vita forse
Perché una persona reale dovrebbe
ascoltare una persona che non esiste
la risposta a queste domande è una sola
perché non ci sentiamo giudicati
oggi Vera sta crescendo al momento è un
progetto editoriale transmediale e la
squadra si sta ampliando comprendendo
artisti digitali sociologi psicologi
persone della comunità lgbt qui a plus
tutti accomunati dalla voglia di
comunicare i valori che vogliamo
trasmettere attraverso questo progetto
transmediale e contemporaneo
il viaggio con un umano digitale può
essere molto positivo perché ci dà
l'opportunità di parlare di umanità di
sensibilizzare e di migliorare
Grazie a personaggi come vera
possiamo esplorare nuovi modi
per esprimere noi stessi di
rappresentare le nostre esperienze di
connetterci con empatia con un pubblico
globale
trovo che sia fondamentale
costruire personaggi in cui le minoranze
vengano viste
includere e non dividere ma condividere
infiniti modi di essere affinché ognuno
possa sentirsi accettato e accolto nel
mondo
il messaggio che oggi vorrei condividere
è che non importa se sei una guerriera
magica o un umano digitale L'importante
è usare la propria voce per fare la
differenza e migliorare il mondo che ci
circonda
Io finalmente grazie a Vera mi sento
come Sailor Moon
il nome della luna
Grazie
[Applauso]